[Música]
[Aplausos]
si tuviera que describirme rápido soy un
apasionado por la tecnología
también por las personas soy un poco
inquieto ansioso que van a ver cómo me
muevo no me gusta mucho mirar televisión
si netflix o decían los chicos antes
tampoco digo mucho los diarios no me
gusta dejarme influenciar mucho por el
humor político aunque si leo noticias de
emprendedurismo y tecnología
y después bueno soy un apasionado de la
cocina me gusta la arquitectura soy un
guitarrista amateur cantante de ducha y
un soñador así que bueno me gustaría
arrancar diciendo yo soy un fiel
creyente de que somos nosotros mismos lo
que forjamos nuestro destino
en mi casa siempre mi mamá me decía sos
vos el que elige cómo reaccionar ante
las cosas que te pasan o no
somos nosotros los que elegimos
enojarnos ante un hecho en particular
cuando tranquilamente podríamos devolver
una sonrisa si quieren irónica pero
somos nosotros
una frase que leí hace muchísimo tiempo
la ley en inglés que decía algo así como
i'm not what happened to mi amor hecho
es to become que significa que yo no soy
las cosas que me pasaron sino que soy lo
que elijo en convertirme y la frase la
traigo un poco a colación porque me trae
la historia de un amigo mío nico
emprendedor también que impactó mucho en
mi vida con lo cual hoy no solamente les
vengo a contar un poquito lo que hago
sino que también vengo a contar esta
historia que tanto impacto
bueno con respecto a mí
de una característica que soy a buscar
lo que lo que sueño o sea no me quedo
solo en el pensamiento en la idea trató
de ejecutar siempre
me parece que las ideas sin ejecución
son solo conceptos más o menos lindos
pero son solo eso
lo que quiero decir es que una idea más
o menos aceptable pero ejecutada siempre
es mucho mejor que la mejor de todas las
ideas sin ejecución así que tengo tiene
tiendo a tener esa esa impronta de
buscar lo que lo que se me ocurre o lo
que se ocurre a la gente que trabaja a
mi contexto
entrando un poco más en la charla
quien no se acuerda del primer trabajo
para algunos no habrán trabajado todavía
pero bueno mi primer trabajo fue una
consultora internacional hoy es la
consultora más grande del mundo
básicamente casi todo lo que sé hacer
laboralmente hoy lo aprendí en esa
empresa con lo cual siento un profundo
agradecimiento a todo lo que aprendí ahí
pero el recuerdo más representativo para
hoy que tengo aquella época
fue que con un grupo de compañeros de la
empresa siempre los miércoles después de
trabajar a la noche cansados nos
juntábamos en la casa de uno de los
chicos a intentar desarrollar proyectos
por nuestra cuenta
básicamente queremos emprender estábamos
soñando bueno eso con el tiempo pasó
hacer dos veces a la semana nos juntamos
martes y jueves y estuvimos
prácticamente un par de años intentando
hacer esto el resultado no emprendimos
nada pero sí aprendimos mucho una época
en la que cada uno fue tomando distintos
roles jugábamos a hacer empresarios o
emprendedores contactamos clientes
proveedores hacíamos cuestiones con lo
cual
aprendimos a emprender un poco si bien
no pudimos concretar nada en esa época
también hubo una segunda fase que tuve
posibilidad de emprender que fue cuando
hice un máster en el jazz con mis
compañeros de estudio también intentamos
emprender en ese momento pero no sé pero
por h o por b por una razón o por la
otra había algo que nos detenía o me
detenía a mí y nunca pudimos avanzar
hasta que bueno un momento de mi vida
que tuvo muchísimo impacto y creo que
suele llamo de tron como en el póker esa
carta que es la cuarta carta que da y
que hace el cambio d
de estilo un poco
el 6 de octubre del 2012 ni con mi amigo
el que les mencioné previamente tuvo un
accidente automovilístico en el que nico
estuvo un año prácticamente para
recuperarse pero lo peor de todo es que
se había quebrado además sino que en ese
accidente falleció su esposa
bueno ese fue un momento durísimo para
nico pero para mí lo particular también
fomentó muy duros mi vida con lo cual
hubo un montón de cuestiones que empecé
a preguntarme
e
y preguntas que quería entender o sea
básicamente quería entender que por qué
pasaron determinadas cosas en la vida yo
en ese momento estaba trabajando en
accenture en esta empresa que les
mencionaba previamente
no sabía qué hacer
básicamente no sabía si seguir la
carrera de la empresa si cambiar de
trabajo si emprender si quedarme a vivir
en buenos aires que era un estado
viviendo sígueme al exterior porque
había posibilidades en perú en chile
o si volver a una vida santa fe que era
algo que me tiraba mucho pero
básicamente no sabía cómo osea para el
tipo de trabajo que yo tenía buenos
aires no había algo similar de santa fe
con lo cual tal vez lo más cercano era
intentar emprender
pero honestamente en ese momento no
tenía ni media idea
y de todas maneras creo que si la
hubiese tenido hubiese sido bastante
difícil porque hubiese significado salir
completamente de mi zona de confort
yo era gerente de una multinacional
tenía muy buen sueldo
muy buen reconocimiento estudiaba todos
los años en chicago
la empresa me pagó un máster en austral
o sea la verdad que hubiese sido un
momento bastante difícil y complejo para
mí hacerlo pero de todas maneras no me
hallo en lo que estaba haciendo
para colmo de males en ese momento
ni con un par de semana más tarde de su
accidente automovilístico o alguna
semana más
como si la vida no fuera misteriosa y a
veces surrealista
el padre muere así en la habitación del
estaba internado en postrado en la cama
un momento la verdad
tristísimo para
en mi vida también porque había pasado
como todos juntos nos decía como puede
ser que estas cosas estas cosas pasan en
la vida
yo fue momento en que realmente empecé a
preguntarme
para que estamos en la vida
indicó tardó un año en volver a caminar
un año entero un tiempo en el que
empezamos atrás empecé a tratar de
valorar para que estábamos en la vida
que era lo que estábamos haciendo cuál
era nuestro propósito único iba
a rehabilitar todos los días empezó
siendo en una camilla en una ambulancia
al tiempo fue en silla de ruedas después
fue en muletas después y en bastón
después reinando
y pasando un momento pésimo la verdad
muy triste y yo recuerdo que
fui testigo de verlos llorar todos los
días pero no se lo mostraba a nadie
el recuerdo que hablaba con el
kinesiólogo y quienes yo luego le decía
hace esta cantidad de ejercicio indicó
hacia el doble el triple
yo me pregunto yo no nos otras veces nos
ponemos mal porque tenemos que hacer un
trámite
o porque se nos puso el semáforo en rojo
o porque perdió en nuestro equipo de
fútbol simplemente cuando hay cosas en
la vida que realmente si tienen valor y
si son importantes
indicó así a todo esto día tras día
valorando que quería salir adelante
entonces un año un año entero de su vida
yo lo que pregunto es
somos conscientes lo que es el tiempo
somos los conscientes lo que gastamos el
tiempo el tiempo se puede gastar pero no
se puede guardar con lo cual tenemos
idea en que gastamos nuestro tiempo en
ese momento estaba tratando de ver qué
hacía con mi vida cuando vi a alguien
que se estaba tratando de levantar para
volver a vivir de nuevo
hasta que un día en una conversación con
él
que me dijo con todo esto lo del
accidente
la pérdida de bueno de su esposa y su
padre dice matt y cambie mi actitud
deje deje de pensar porque a mí
porque a mí me pasó esto y empecé a
pensar porque a mí no porque a mí no me
puede pasar si estas cosas pasan en la
vida que tengo especial para que no me
pase
y tengo que hacer está súper fuerte que
es practicar la aceptación
bueno nos adelante nosotros mismos
hacernos cargo nuestras cuestiones
y yo dije ok y empecé a pensar solo
también porque a mí no porque no había
podido emprender porque a mí no me puede
salir bien un emprendimiento porque no
porque a mí no me puede salir bien las
cosas porque no porque no me puede dar
bola a la chica que me gusta cualquier
cosa porque no fomento en el que
recuerdo que empecé a desafiarme
muchísimo
gracias a esta experiencia
hasta que bueno un día
yo estaba haciendo mi último proyecto en
relación de dependencia
y me llega un mail de de it and de hoy
amigo en su momento hoy es amigo y socio
es un amigo que conocí en su momento en
buenos aires de california y me manda
este mail y me dice
si conoces a alguna empresa de diseño
gráfico en santa fe porque acá tengo un
cliente que tiene que hacer 500 vectores
por semana
imagina en mi cara vectores o sea que es
un vector
500 número quinientos 500 vectores y
quien entonces mucho muchísimo poco nada
cuestión que sin saber de qué se trataba
la cosa me contacte con 34 diseñadores y
con una al cabo de un par de semanas
empezamos el proyecto recuerde fue el 24
de enero de 2014
y al cabo de tres meses éramos 25
personas trabajando hacia los 500 vector
eran bastantes
así que
al crecer lo que es un vector es una
técnica para la impresión de remeras en
serigrafía así que bueno fue un año
espectacular por fin pude emprender
fue un año de crecimiento en todos los
aspectos de mi vida o sea laboral
personal económico
la verdad que era soñado pero bueno no
todo es color de rosa sobre todo cuando
se emprende por primera vez ahí hay
muchos excesos de confianza mucha
inmadurez sobre todo si las cosas van
bien
cuestión que él se unió fue un desastre
o sea se cayó el castillo de naipes y
fue un desastre en todo sentido se halla
la plata no alcanzaba de casualidad que
alcanzaba para apagar el equipo de
trabajo
y fue un momento de realmente de cambio
para mí porque realmente ya no servía lo
que había servido el año anterior y lo
que pensé que de alguna manera lograr
para siempre
para con nueve mares
único que ya estaba caminando estaba
emprendiendo y estaba de novio se había
dado la posibilidad volver a estar de
novio
voy a pasar otro momento pésimo eso que
decir no se lo deseo a nadie
en dos meses fallece su madre se pelea
con la novia que había una oportunidad
de nuevo
y
el socio y amigo de toda la vida lo
estafa lo dejas sin clientes lo deja con
deudas y lo peor de todo con el equipo a
su cargo
bueno nico en ese momento
charlo con su equipo él tenía un dinero
ahorrado le sirvió para tirar seis meses
mientras conseguía clientes que no es
fácil conseguir clientes en un mercado
con eeuu
pero lo más importante de todo es que no
he hecho a nadie cumplió con su promesa
y lo terminó logrando
yo
en ese momento estaba emprendiendo mi
segundo proyecto que es en vive es una
empresa de tecnología
y también como había tenido mis errores
en el pasado
en ese momento decidí hacer las cosas
bien no contraté un abogado contraté un
contador una chica de marketing y me
ayude promocionar la empresa la verdad
que fue un éxito anduvo muy bien
suele ser raíz de emprendedor porque una
vez que parece que es como una
enfermedad cuando empiezas a emprender
en esa raíz de emprendedor arrancó otro
proyecto tal vez el proyecto más grande
de mi vida es un proyecto de llama
inicial station es un polo tecnológico
en la ciudad santa fe son 50 mil metros
cuadrados
proyecto que está avanzando y por hoy no
a nivel constructivo pero sí a nivel
aprobaciones
lo hicimos con un equipo de ocho
arquitectos y dos locos más que se
sumaron y dio locos porque todos
trabajaron a don oren por un sueño sin
pedir nada a cambio
y siguen trabajando esto fue un proyecto
de un año y medio prácticamente y es un
equipo que tiene un
un factor motivacional y
transformacional muy muy pero muy fuerte
cuestión que este proyecto nos trajo un
montón de exposición
salimos en todos los diarios salimos en
canales de televisión en radio e
inclusive vino el intendente la ciudad
santa fe a nuestra empresa
y toda esta exposición no sólo hizo que
consolidemos un montón de los proyectos
que ya teníamos en marcha sino que trajo
nuevos proyectos
las cuatro empresas son de arriba en de
pixel high power lab y cocina en altura
es una empresa de marca en
funcionamiento las tres que siguen track
out loud' agua deriven en fin son
proyectos próximos a convertirse en
empresas y los sueños de abajo inicial
stage son el polo tecnológico y urban
prop el um un estudio arquitectura que
armamos para con estos chicos le
mostraba antes para ejecutar el proyecto
recuerdan cuando les dije antes si
sabíamos en qué gastamos nuestro tiempo
si somos conscientes en que gastamos
nuestro tiempo
esto pasó en dos años no más son nueve
proyectos cuatro marchas tres casi en
marcha y dos más de largo plazo tan sólo
en dos años
por eso
yo creo que no se puede construir el
futuro con los prejuicios del presente
creo que luego de soñar hay que hacer
creo que lo importante no es lo que
hacemos sino el impacto de lo que
hacemos
creo que motivación y propósito son dos
condimentos fundamentales para que
podamos amar lo que hacemos
creo que si tenemos miedo hay que
hacerlo con miedo
creo que las personas positivas no saben
de plan b
si fallan crean otro plan a
creo que no hay que dejar que los sueños
sean solo sueños
creo que los malos momentos
tienen demasiada mala prensa y nadie
valora que son los momentos que nos
llevan de un buen momento otro buen
momento
creo que todas las personas podemos
cumplir nuestros sueños
y creo que somos nosotros mismos los que
forjamos nuestro futuro
y nico es amigo que le sigo contando del
principio era realmente eso
esta fue una historia que sucedió al
mismo tiempo lo bueno y lo malo lo
blanco y lo negro lo positivo y lo
negativo
por eso yo creo que las malas cosas
pueden suceder buenas cosas
se descubrió un emprendedor que
desconocía que no tenía ni idea que
existía
me descubrí haciendo cosas que jamás
pensé que podía hacer formando equipos
creo realmente fehacientemente que somos
nosotros los que nos tenemos que hacer
cargo de las cosas creo que cuando nos
pasa algo malo somos nosotros los que
tenemos que salir adelante y poner la
cara que no importa cuántas veces nos
fundamos cuántas pérdidas ya hemos
tenido creo lo importante es levantar la
cabeza mi gracia adelante y seguir
caminando porque yo creo que eso es lo
que necesita la vida del emprendedor
resiliencia
y así fue como único y matemático nos
apoyamos
para estos dos años a pesar de las
dificultades vivir un sueño casi real
y esto es un homenaje a esas tres
personas que fallecieron que hoy no
están los dos y mi mamá y con carlos mi
viejo
por todo lo que me enseñaron por toda la
fortaleza que me dieron a pesar de la
pérdida
pero también es un homenaje a todas las
personas de mi vida
a todas las personas con las que me
quedo porque todas
y las miro
de todas y de cada una
por mucho por poco por bueno por malo
yo aprendí algo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]